Mikor lesz egy műalkotás propaganda és
mikor igazi művészet? Az a az egyik
probléma, hogy a
propaganda az negatív értelmű az
általában az embereknek. Pedig a
propaganda az mi? A propaganda igazából
egy egy kommunikációs stratégia,
amelyikben megszűrünk meg megszűrten
kommunikálunk valamit. Tehát szelektíven
kommunikálunk.
És most, hogyha ennek van igen az van,
hogy ez negatív értelmű lett, de van az
a propaganda, amelyik egészségüggyel
kapcsolatos kampány mondjuk, vagy
vagy társadalmi érzékenységre, de ez már
nem művészet fókuszoló fókusz, de lehet
művészet, lehet művészet. A másik dolog,
hogy a művész az folyamatosan szelektál.
Tehát amikor ő egy témáról beszél, nem
tud objektíven és mindent bemutatni,
tehát nem tudod lefesteni az egész
világot, csak egy t kiemelsz belőle egy
részletet, és arra fókuszálsz.